lustig lustig nikolaus am falschen ort
partypeople und leute und hobbys und wir
sind hier wieder bei russisch roulette
doch die kugel sagt ich bin nicht gesagt
was du nicht weißt die jeweils die
hälfte
die auf g j
ein möglicher weg gehen wie hoch das
inventar drin gehabt dass nicht auf sie
schießen können warum gibt sich
abgeschossen
ich bin erst wieder hoch
das loch in der wand bitte wir kommen
hierher kann man konsumiert gucken wir
mal an wo bist du denn hier vorne bist
du unten
hier bleib hier stehen wo ich jetzt bin
ich weil ich sicher zu gehen
nein
wer keiner besser da keiner psa psa
lange mit dem backen wollte mich waschen
war wohl nächste jahr war wohl nix
endlich okay der troll im tor steht
jetzt glaube ich so zehn zu eins wir
müssen hier irgendwie in die komplette
also bleib dran für weitere tritium
leute fest wir müssen ihnen dieses
abwasser vorbei wir müssen in das
abwasserrohr waren wir unglaublich
nein vor diese tricky rätseln oder die
monster zu bekommen glaubt voran weil
diese teams hat er hier kompass heraus
sondern verein nicht kommen die fenster
guckt auch den hintern
ich habe wenig verbessert
ich würde die kartoffel drin wo da kann
man so eine epische slow motion
reinpacken alter muss man schießen
du musst in den tunnel reinschießen so
warum das dann wird ihr porträt nee nee
da sind so wieder holz druckplatten aber
ich habe ein genial platte ganz einfach
in die links in die indianer einspringt
und dann ziemlich gefällt und wie man
hört noch nichts da muss man irgendwann
schaltet dann höre ich glücklich nicht
zugelegt dienstag gegeben haben also
eigentlich an ideen alter wenn ich das
schaffe dann feiere ich möchte ein kind
mussten sie in slow motion präsident
rupert
ja ihr schafft es geschafft
ich will was klar ist dass weg macht
warum war mir das so klar warum man kann
das nicht machen
du bist du scheiße kann das sein kann es
gab mal sein weil hier ist nicht dieser
hat sich gerade geschlossen hält der
verband
also ich lese mal vor was hier steht gut
bis sehr gut erzielen oder einfach sehr
der rassisten
sturköpfe ich okay weil dieser dieser
letzte raum ist schwer zu schaffen
okay kommt einfach her jetzt geht's hier
weiter in letztere werden im stranger
hier kann man eigentlich nicht sein
letzter als wichtig ganz wichtig leute
schreibt in die kommentare
ob eine fortsetzung wollt es gibt noch
teil 2 und teil 3 das wir alle genug
material wenn ihr bock habt lasst uns
das wissen lassen dass sie da und weil
die resonanz stimmt also direkt meinung
stimmt dann seid ihr auf jeden fall
weitermachen
wie jeder weiß gehört es sich nicht
anders als im netz in der letzten folge
von einer sowie web alles gute
verbindung zahlen gibt die firma gaylord
14 alles gebaut
die besten
die explosion des lebens
allen oberflächen entstehen
wir machen fehlte wie weit das hier in
der erde geguckt was der dings gesagt
hat der geist ist der dümmste wie du
geschrieben hast ja klar
ein riesiger berg
hier ist die stadt ich würde sagen
ok ich muss von hinten starten die
kunden sind es eigentlich keine ahnung
ja klar
und schwester
wir sind bei campbell den krankhaft da
nickt ich hatte gerade den internet
absturz des todes alles war weg
nein ich bin schon hollywood dem haus
geht mehr gibt mir eine chance zu rennen
nein wir haben ja aber ich bin ich
gestorben
ok also dann würde ich sagen dass er
mich noch mal quälen will ein kleines
battle wo bist du denn hin wohin wohl
kämpfen kann
wir müssen jetzt eine auftrag mal
schluss machen weil die vaterschaft
super lang wechselt sie mir erklären
erklären warum wir gerade ein snowball
lag
oh mein gott dann gehts ja dann gehts ja
dann gehts ja verpiss dich als du bist
auch überhaupt nicht im alter du bist so
ein user du bist so echt ein krasser
looser jetzt tp mich zurück gemacht noch
einen battle junge wirklich die frage
ist schon todes lang doch gar nicht
stimmt doch gar nicht ich habe gold
warum ja schön dass du uns loslegen
jetzt soll die jungs schaffen wir können
es schaffen
wir können den reuigen kran besiegeln
häufig gegen entfernt
nein nie den bug des todes alter eine
feile fall nicht alter diesel folgende
die wird so hornemann ja ja ja halt dein
maul alter super hätten für die sache
nicht also maximal teilweise kurz davor
zu verrecken das ist für mich als ja
minecraft neuling doch noch eine
ziemlich gute leistung vor allem aber
immer sagt aber der geilste okay damit
verabschieden wir uns manchmal sagen
eine weitere episode haben sollte hier
ein bisschen ganz cool und lustig ja
falls ich gefallen hat lassen like und
einen kommentar da und gibt uns lasst
uns damit wissen ob ihr noch mehr haben
wollte ich habe ihn getötet und dann
können wir die folge peace out leute ich
bin besser